you're doing it right in your own way
daily wire is doing their part you doing
your part you got a couple of these guys
that are doing what they're doing to
protect their own uh
values and principles that they have
what feedback would you give to folks
who are in the church who are asking why
are memberships down why is attendance
down why is the
the tithing and involvement down
second if you talk to some of these guys
who are
i'm not talking about the larry honors
of the world we've had larry arnon from
claremont institute larry yarn
i'm not talking about those guys who are
doing their part with school education
i'm talking about some of the guys that
are sitting on the sidelines that are
wondering what can we do about it to get
more creative what feedback would you
give them well first of all i wouldn't
probably be a consultant for them
because i just make jokes on the
internet so they'd be stupid to ask me
but if they did ask me i think that i
think that right now the left is
creating a massive opportunity
by going completely woke by making all
kinds of rules about what you can do and
what you can say you must be vaccinated
you must not make you must use the
proper pronouns you must not say they
try to compel speech they try to compel
thought they try to make certain
thoughts crimes certain words crimes and
they do that in entertainment areas
comedians are feeling that pressure we
talked about dave chappelle briefly
chappelle's feeling that pressure but
here's the thing
we're talking about chappelle and he's
getting more views than anybody else the
people who are willing to make the jokes
you're not supposed to make and say the
things you're not supposed to say are
going to have a massive massive audience
because that major they call it like the
silent majority that got trump voted
right there was always like people were
wondering where's all the support for
trump come from there were a lot of
people who were like holding that in and
not talking about their support for
trump until they got to the ballot box
and they voted for him there's a lot of
people in this country a huge huge huge
percentage of people in this country who
reject all of that kind of uh
uh
control and they just want personal
liberty they want personal freedom they
want to live and let live
and they want real comedy they want
people to be able to joke about things
anything and nothing off limits you know
and just and actually engage in real
conversation entertainment that's not
watered down with all the things you're
supposed to say and supposed to do so i
think okay so what daily wire is doing
is a great model they're taking people
who've been canceled like gina carano
and i don't know the name of the espn
personality um they're gonna you're
gonna continue to see people do this
where they gobble up the canceled people
and serve those people right back to
an audience uh that's even bigger than
the one that they had before i think
that that's going to be a winning model
in the future especially as
as you try as they is they basically try
to create ideological conformity in all
of these areas people are going to push
back on that i think they're going to
push back hard that creates market
opportunity in my opinion so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and please don't
forget to subscribe to the channel take
care everybody bye
[Music]